l'exhibitionniste christian louboutin
s'expose au palais de la porte dorée à
paris le lieu même où lui est venue la
fascination pour le soulier quand il
était enfant
en fait j'étais allé dans un musée où
j'avais vu un grand dessein qui était un
croquis qui représentait un soulier et
il était barré de rouge
je me disais tiens c'est bizarre
pourquoi ont barré de rouge un township
au total ont comme très très haut très
pointu c'est pour pas casser les
parquets mais l'idée l'interdît comme ça
ne m'amusais tellement pire c'est quand
même existence impunis tient bon bah
voilà
et c'est ainsi qu'au début des années 90
christian louboutin s'approprie
l'escarpin de création le talon est
vertigineux et la semelle rouge dès les
premiers modèles
elle colle aux pieds des stars la
chaussure par louboutin séduit des états
unis puis le monde antique mais la
portée n'est pas chose aisée la semelle
en cuir glisse sur les surfaces lisses
elle doit être traitée par un cordonnier
je suis énervé d'entendre je peux pas
courir avec ses souliers là et tous les
souliers sont pas faites pour courir
d'égaler celui qui sont faits pour
courir s'appelle des baskets pas de
baskets pour le bouton mais l'anti
basket en 2007 il crée des souliers qui
ne se portent pas des pièces d'art en
collaboration avec david lynch il expose
des pères objet de fantasmes et de
fétichisme avec un travail particulier
sur le talon quand on aime dessiner les
souliers de femmes ce qui est très
important c'est le talon et donc il ya
une certaine manière elle est d un jour
de dessiner l'ultime talons l'ultime
talent certain talent ont pratiquement
impossible l'ultime talent c'est
vraiment lapointe combien certaine
manière
plus inédit encore en 2009 nos boutin
dessine une chaussure qui ne se porte
pas au pied mais à la bouche un soulier
de cristal à remplir de champagne comme
cela pouvait se voir à la fin du 19e
siècle et à cette époque là pour faire
la cour aux documents des noms cocotte
ou aux femmes de l'époque on buvait dans
leurs souliers
alors on a trouvé que c'était une idée
intéressante pour une nouvelle idée
nouvelle manière de consommer champagne
alors même si le confort de nos pieds
lui apporte peu croft luxe de même s'il
ne court pas après le comfort ses
chaussures trouve des adeptes dans le
monde entier chaque année il se vend des
centaines de milliers de paires de
louboutin
[Musique]